my name is doji and I am going to go
ahead and be giving you a talk on just
some basics for web design some ways
that you can get into it and some things
that you can do so that it doesn't feel
like this foreign thing so that design
doesn't feel like something that is
unapproachable except for the best of
all the best designers really quick
my name is doji my parents are from
Ghana and that's why my name is the way
it is the DeeZee is a J I was born in
Oklahoma though which is kind of cool I
work as a volunteer for an organization
called the interaction design foundation
and what they do is their goal is to
really promote design education
especially UX design and human-computer
interaction and I work as the local
leader in the Oklahoma area I'm just
trying to gather people together
regularly to talk about design topics
and to really tell them it's not this
thing that cannot be approached that
everyone can actually do it and you just
need to learn about the basics and you
can slowly work your way up from there I
use Erb foundation as a framework for
doing web design and web pages I like it
a lot so if I lean towards pushing ZURB
that's the reason why it isn't because
it's the best it's just I like it that's
about it find what you like use it and
I'm also a tech Lahoma
volunteer as well so from here on out
I'll be helping with some other
organizations here at Oklahoma where
we're going to be getting together and
once again trying to bridge between tech
the development and then the design part
as well there'll be announcements about
that later on so keep posted on the tech
Lahoma website for that today what we're
going to go through is first design and
design thinking and this is really what
you want to do to get into solving a
problem so we're going to talk about
what design is then I'm gonna get you
some tools and some basic knowledge so
that you have something to base
everything off of and you're not just in
the wild like what's this design
what's going on and then a workflow
having a workflow makes it easier for
you to go from start to finish I'll just
show you one there are lots of them and
as soon as you get comfortable you can
adopt your own with no problems and
we're going to do some small case
studies they're not really case study
level but I'm taking some elements live
from the web and then I'm going to be
using those and then finally some
resources to get you started I have some
books over here at the end of the talk
you can look through those are my
recommendations with books and I really
think they can help get you on your way
the slides will be online as well and
any links that I have are on those
slides so don't worry about those either
so now let's go ahead and talk about
design and Design Thinking these are the
basics this is where we're starting from
and what is design I would like to say I
have the ultimate answer to that but I
don't they're greater Minds than me who
still have difficulty talking about it
so I'm just going to give you the basic
basic it's solving problems for humans
in a way that can be approached by
humans that's basically it you design
lots of different things
design can mean lots of different things
for example if I say this podium is
well-designed
am I talking about the aesthetic does it
look really good or am I talking about
how it's really easy to stand behind is
it a balance between the two and those
are all things that you need to consider
whenever you're going through design as
well it's problem solving and problem
solving is really difficult I wish that
I were the strongest being in the world
and I had a magical gauntlet that could
solve all design problems snap my
fingers and everything's good but
usually this is what it looks like
that's what you got so mm-hmm ballast I
got you let's go ahead with some design
thinking so this is the pattern for
design thinking and basically what
you're doing is it looks like a straight
line you empathize with the user and
what empathy and empathizing is is
understanding the problems of the user
from the users
spective you really want to know what
the user is dealing with what the issue
is why they're dealing with something
I've had up till now lots of problems
with math I'm a full-time software
developer and I do lots of things but
math is one of those things that I still
can't really break the barrier on my dad
is amazing at math I don't know why I
didn't get any of those genes oh well
but when I talked to him about math and
I say I'm having this issue can you
teach me he says to me that's easy oh
it's just this business assistance and
is done and I'm like we're okay and we
have this disconnect and I can't talk to
him about math because he isn't able to
empathize with me at my point in time
with where I'm at right however there
are other people who I've talked to
about math who say oh yeah I remember I
had difficulties with that and that's
how I dealt with it for example I had a
difficulties with programming I'm like
how come I can't make a equal to X and
now it's not an issue but I remember
that and I empathize with people who are
in that situation so I understand the
problem and I know how to talk about it
when it comes to design you want to do
the same thing you want to understand
what the user is dealing with I don't
like the page okay why don't they like
the page the buttons are all over the
place I understand what the issue is
it's hard to navigate this page that's
where the empathy comes in so we've
empathize with the user we understand
that the buttons all over the page
that's why they're having difficulty so
now we need to define the problem the
problem is the buttons need to be
centrally located so we go to our next
step
ideation where you go through and you
find different ways to solve the problem
and after you've done your ideation you
say these are number of ways that I can
solve my problem you make a prototype
this is the thing this is how we're
gonna solve it you test it and then
you're done yay we design something
we're good to go except it doesn't quite
work that way
maybe you get to testing and you realize
that your testing stage that you
really understand what the problem was
so you go back because you now empathize
with the user you understand what was
going on you go back and you say this is
what the real problem is let's start all
the steps again or maybe you're testing
and you're like this this is good but I
have a better idea of how to make things
better or you made a prototype or like
wait this prototype inspired me to do
more things I have more ideas of how I
can solve this and you can keep going
that way basically it's not a linear
process don't think of it as a linear
process you can probably start in the
middle you can start at ideation and
then work your way backwards it's very
organic so don't worry about that so now
we understand Design Thinking now we're
going to go to solving the problem I
have concept cars up here and the cool
thing about concept cars is a car can be
pretty much anything they all solve our
problem our problem number one problem
is how did you get here most likely you
had some form of transportation to get
right here and the car solved that
problem we could go back to horses you
could totally get here that solved a
problem for a little bit but the problem
was we wanted to get there faster safer
with less poop on the streets so we had
invented the car and the cars have
issues too
no we don't poop in the streets but we
have stuff in the air now so there are
electric cars so what are you ever
you're solving your problems you have a
lot of ways you can do it we have for
example the concept car this one right
over here and that's amazing concept
cars are awesome because it's like I can
do anything look at this this is the
coolest car and I totally wouldn't want
to ride in it because I totally look
like a dweeb or something it's just
crazy but it is a form of design it's
saying how far can we push the
boundaries when you look at web design
you can say the same thing how far can i
push the boundaries you're making a
portfolio site for yourself you might
want to push those boundaries they can
show that I know the technology
I know what's behind the design and I
know how to push it so that's one way to
solve a problem we also have over here
the luxury car that is pretty cool it's
precise it has all the features you need
but it's also unattainable for most of
us I drive a Ford I'm probably never
going to afford a BMW unfortunately so
it's not quite attainable its those
services that companies pay $2,000 a
month for subscriptions right they have
a lot of different features they're
really elegant that's also a way to
solve a problem right finally we have
the consumer model right over here it
checks all the boxes I can get from A to
B it's safe enough it has enough
features for my day-to-day and it's
approachable I can say ok I can buy one
of these cars and that's how you want to
look at your designs as well who is
going to be approaching it speaking of
which we really want to think about the
users context what context who is the
user what are we trying to do and what
is the context are they is this for work
is this personal is it business is it
casual that's something you want to
think about are they on their mobile
phones are they on their tablets or are
they working on a desktop now it's very
important to think about that because I
have an example over here and the wild
you might want to take a look at this I
like to download sounds and mess with
sounds so I use a program and I'm not
calling this company out okay but it's
just it works for this presentation I
used something called splice and I can
download my sounds and I'm like well I
have an iPad I'm gonna get the splice
app for my iPad and iPad iPad is pretty
big I hold it like this I want to be at
my desk I want the extra screen real
estate that's why I got one of these big
things and this is what I get very
cumbersome for me to use because it was
designed to be used on an iPhone so now
I have to use my
tablet like an iPhone that it doesn't
really work no so you want to think
about context a lot that's very very
very important next we will actually
want to think about a approach to our
content so you're going to be presenting
content to the user in some shape or
form there are lots of ways to do it I'm
just going to show you some examples
these are what I've distilled it down to
but there's more they're hybrids and
there are other applications as well but
first we might have email you might make
an email message I'm sure you've all
gotten those marketing email messages in
your inbox the responsive emails they're
really well designed you can apply your
web design and HTML skills there you can
also go with the web page we've all seen
them this is Google Way back in the day
before they went into their design
overhaul there's a dashboard where
you're presenting metrics to lots of
different people and they want to see
everything on one screen in as concise
as possible next we also have an app a
full-blown app and these get really
complicated but it is a way to present
content so we've gone through we've
looked at design we know what's going on
with design how to start our problem how
to solve it now I'm gonna give you the
basic tools and knowledge so that you
know where to go from here because you
can't build something with all the tools
you can't build a house without nails
wood and a lot of other things now so
here are the tools of the trade
we need pen and paper I recommend graph
paper and you might be wondering if
we're doing digital design why are we
doing everything on paper well the
biggest reason we're doing things on
paper is because that's the fastest way
to get your ideas down analog is much
faster for so much than digital is I
love tech I have a ton of computers at
home my wife has to deal with my
girlfriend
which are computers so I just I love
tech and the analog way is just faster
than dealing with tech a lot of the time
so you want to get comfortable with pen
and paper and sketching if you're not
comfortable with sketching I do have a
book that I recommend and I'll talk
about that later you also want some
mock-up and prototyping tools and the
reason that you need these tools are
after you have your sketches down you
want to make them presentable to
somebody else if you can't present them
as an idea if you can't pitch them to
somebody if you can't walk them through
this is how I'm going to build up your
website this is how I'm going to redo
your app this is how we're going to run
your marketing campaign then you can't
communicate so this is a way to start
communicating you want a few web
browsers you want the default on your
computer but you probably also want
Firefox and Chrome because people access
websites and web media different ways
and a website on one computer might show
up slightly different on another so you
want to make sure you have a few to test
with and finally you want a text editor
and you want to find one that you love I
like sublime text 3 I don't recommend it
for everybody because there's an upfront
cost of like $70 it's really good there
are others that are free as well like
Visual Studio code Adam those are great
ones and they all support the industry
very well you can do web development
across all of them I recommend ones that
are cross-platform you can use them on
Mac or Windows because maybe you have a
Mac and you're working and you go to a
company that only has Windows well if
it's cross-platform you can still use
your tools so try and look for
cross-platform solutions when possible
now we have our tools to make our
wireframes
mock-ups and our prototypes like I said
start low Phi because drawing in analog
is much faster and easier to change the
cost of changing a drawing is a new
piece of paper writing things down
really quickly Wi-Fi Wi-Fi whenever you
go a little bit higher it takes a little
bit more time to go
that because you have to go through and
manipulate your elements change how they
are resize things and it just takes a
little bit more time and then whatever
you're dealing with a full-blown
prototype and somebody says can we shift
this to the left 10 pixels that's when
your world is over because changing it
at that point in time is really
expensive so try and get everything out
in the drawing stage communicate lots of
sticky notes there ways to do this and
some of the books that I have to
actually go through the methodology for
how to go through and do your lo-fi
drawing up to your prototypes next if
you're doing web design you have to you
know CSS and how to work with CSS
selectors I had difficulties with this
for a little bit but then I found a
plug-in for a text editor called Emmet
and what Emmet does is it allows you to
write HTML using CSS selectors and I
have an example I'm gonna go ahead and
pop that up over here I just have some
text and let's see if I can see where my
cursor is and you can see right over
here it says table dot information and
the dot would be a class in my table and
I have a table row and then table cells
over here and I have times 3 down here
and with a match if you haven't
installed and it can be installed in any
one of those editors I talked about
before you are writing these CSS
selectors and you hit the tab button and
then you get HTML so it saves you in
writing HTML it saves you and missing
close tags and it also teaches you CSS
selectors at the same time because
that's the way to use the tool so you're
getting three birds with one stone as to
no just two or even one which is pretty
cool
next we're going to go to the next slide
design patterns so you might be thinking
well design is amazing but I've never
done it I don't know how to do it well
there are these things called design
patterns and it's common ways to address
problems there are lots of components so
you don't have to start from complete
scratch basically going through with
these for example this is a carousel
that you're seeing up on the screen and
they're just ways for you to organize
content manage data input work with
search boxes autocomplete drop-down
boxes etc those are all called design
patterns and I have a list over here
there's more as well and I have links to
where you can see more about design
patterns but it's just an easier way to
approach it so you know oh if I'm gonna
make that webpage I need a tab
navigation I'm going to need a few
drop-down boxes some text and foot and a
search field and by doing that you
simplify the design process because
you're not doing everything from scratch
from the beginning next you want to
understand the basics of responsive
design and with that example with splice
that wasn't a responsive app it was made
for cell phone and then they just
stretched it so if I had a tablet that
was this big I would have to hold it
like this it's very cumbersome it just
it doesn't make sense but with
responsive design what you're doing is
saying people are going to approach
content from different devices in
different ways I need to make sure that
my content adapts to their device and I
don't need to force them to adapt to my
content this has been around for a while
it's a very good approach to design for
the web and for apps and software as
well jumping into it straight off is
difficult so I recommend that you jump
into a front-end framework of some sort
I recommend foundation I've used it it's
really great they've been around for a
long time it's very simple easy to read
bootstrap is also very good balm and
skeleton are good as well
and you might wonder like in the
age that we have the CSS grid why would
I need a front-end framework well it's a
more approachable way to get your design
up and running from the beginning and
you don't have to fight with it as much
and the CSS grid is really good if
you're in a company that's working from
scratch on a new system I would
recommend using the CSS grid because the
company owns all of that and you can
tailor it to your needs however if
you're making your own webpage or you're
working on a webpage for somebody else
and it's just needs to be up there and
you want it to be responsive and you
don't want to have to put in all the
work of customizing all the different
controls I most definitely recommend a
front-end framework next let's take a
look at a workflow so we need to figure
out how we're going to work through
things to get from start to finish
and this is usually how you go through
it you do a rough pass you do a
prototyping pass and then you do a
finishing pass so your rough pass is
basically doing all your sketches and
these are some sketches I did they're
not good they're just I sketched on
paper I used the graph paper to help me
draw straight lines otherwise I can't
draw straight lines so that's why I
recommend graph paper lots of notes
arrows like this is where I want it to
go this is if you click here this is
where it goes to that's what you're
thinking about whenever you're in the
paper prototyping stage that's really
what you want to do sketch a lot just
keep sketching as soon as you're like
I'm done sketching for today that's
about when you should stop but keep
sketching until you hit that after
you've hit that point take a break take
a breather go someplace listen to some
music play some video games do something
else whatever floats your boat come back
with a fresh mind and then start
transitioning your sketches over to
using digital tools so like a mock-up
tool Islamic mock-ups is really good it
looks very 1990s but that's perfect
because you don't want your mock-ups to
be too hi-fi
there's also Adobe XD and I would
recommend that for prototyping
not as much for mock-ups because when
you're an XD or start talking colors and
fonts and everything and it's too early
for that you really want to stay low fie
everything rough so that you have the
freedom to change things around next we
go into prototyping this is where you
would jump into Adobe XD and what are my
colors and what do I do
so you have a hi-fi a hi-5 sketch like I
have over here I did that in bosonic and
I just click a button and it becomes
hi-fi and then you might want to start
looking at colors what am I going to do
with colors you might make a mood board
and a mood board can be a collection
it's an eclectic collection of lots of
things together that says this is the
mood we're going for this is kind of
what we want our finished product to
look like feel like and B and at the
beginning starting off and jumping into
a mood board mood board can seem very
daunting but they're easy ways to get
there and I'm going to show you one
first you can see that this one has five
colors I have five color swatches and
there's an easy way to get here we can
go ahead and on this screen I have Adobe
colors CC and what it does is it allows
you to get colors from a picture or
start with your own color palettes so
you can go in and if I navigate over
there from there you can move these
colors around and it's going to try and
based on a color you choose it gives you
complimentary colors or other colors
that might match now what I like to do
is with your mood board you might be
looking on the internet for pictures
like I had in mind so you get a picture
and you tell color that you're going to
start from an image I have Avengers
images over here apparently I like The
Avengers let's go ahead and take a look
at what happens if we toss Tony Stark
Iron Man in here awesome and it goes
through and it makes a color palette for
us
it's that easy and obviously as you go
into doing more design they're going to
be intricacies that you're going to deal
with but starting out for just a five
tone color theme you can do something
like this I got Iron Man over here these
colors look pretty okay I might need to
use white as the text color if I'm going
to use black as the background and then
the other colors is trim or buttons over
there that works sometimes you might
toss a picture in and it just doesn't
work let's see what else we have
I have Spider Man from the 10th
anniversary let's go ahead and yeah that
really doesn't work it's you know and it
happens but you can go through and there
are other ways to navigate around you
can I might not be able to see it over
here it's back to the wheel and that is
back to my image let's try the Hulk
that's okay you could go ahead and
choose styles and that changes it so you
can change it like oh that's better I
could probably work with that and do
something with it
so that's a good way to go ahead and
start choosing your colors so back to
prototyping we also want to talk about
fonts just a little bit so you see I
have some fonts that I just decided to
mess with them like okay how can I match
these fonts I have a really bold slab
style font and then I have a sans
sarah style font over here that i tossed
in as well and we can work with that
there are tools to work with that as
well my goal is to get you the tools to
start working with them instead of being
afraid of them and one way you can do
that is we can do a web search and this
is a web page I just typed in font
pairings 20 perfect font pairings so
other people who are really really into
typography went through and said if you
pair these fonts depending on what
you're doing you should be pretty okay
and you can just
through and see some font pairings and
say oh these are some fonts that I want
to go through and it's good to know what
a sans-serif font is and what a serif
font is at the beginning and as you go
over time you'll get more in depth and
understanding what's going on but yeah
we'll scroll down and I think over here
at number nine is what I wanted to use
there's the liberation serif and sans
serif and as you can see the serif font
has little flares at the ends and the
serif the sans serif font is very
flattened straight that's pretty much
the difference and they said that you
can pair these so we might want to use
the serif font as a header and then the
censor for our body and one way you can
do that is we are going to go on to
google fonts and you can choose some
fonts we I typed in Lib ahead of time so
they don't exactly have the fonts that
we're there but they have some things
that are pretty close these two right
over here they are fairly close let's go
ahead and see if I can add so you would
add it like this and then it gives you
the CSS and the link for actually
tossing that into someplace now there is
one more tool on top of that that I
would want to use after we've had our
font selected and I have some other
things going on on my screen right now
so that I can show you what's going on
there is a tool called grid lover and in
grid lover you can experiment with fonts
so it has the font here and you can use
the little buttons up at the top to
navigate between the different panels
here's the link panel where you'd put
your link text let me get my link text
so that it will talk to the Google font
provider and you'll get those two fonts
that we looked at over there so I can
paste them in
and I paste them in here that's awesome
and I said that I would use one for the
body and one for the header so for the
body where you for the header we're
using the serif font have that over here
and I've copied the code for that and
I'm going to try and paste this in here
there you go
I don't paste that there we can see it
changes so you can start working with
fonts that way
that's another header and we can just
see how it works with our headers that's
a little too big we might want to reduce
that but just to show you for example so
that is an example of what we did with
these serif headers and then we can also
toss in our sans-serif body as well to
see how that changes things and I would
encourage you to use this tool and
experiment with it so that you can see
what's going on with your designs so
let's go with the body this is what we
have over here and I'm going to change
it with the code from google fonts and
that's how it changes it so you can
experiment this way you don't have to
set up a web page you can just go to
this web page toss on font combinations
see what you think and see how you like
them very very handy awesome next we're
going to go to polishing up your work so
we've already talked about deciding on
some fonts and thinking about font
pairings and how to work with the fonts
you also want to reduce image sizes
you're working with somebody who has a
cell phone they're downloading a web
page I'm sure we've all had it how many
of you have had a web page that just
takes forever to load on your phone
everyone okay
a lot of times what's happening is they
gave you the desktop version of the
image and your phone is trying to
download all of that it wastes your
bandwidth on your phone it takes up your
packets or whatever you use per month
and it's also slow so you want to find
ways to reduce it it's called responsive
images and there are lots of ways that
you can deal with it I recommend you go
and search for are using responsive
images and responsive designs to get
started with that you also want to
leverage an icon pack
and the reason that you want to go with
an icon pack is instead of going through
and designing each and every one of
these icons right here that takes a long
time their icon designers out there that
that's all they do they make icons so
that you can use them get one of those
toss them in your design you can color
them using CSS it's very handy and it
saves you time so once again the whole
design thing is you don't have to do
everything with design you just need to
know how to come Bob you late if that's
a word just come Bob you lates a word
the different parts of design so that
you can get what you want to work with
okay let's go ahead and take a look at
some case studies we have all the
information that I've given you so far
and I'm going to give you some more
information whenever it comes to design
like where do I put something how should
I color it what do I want it to be how
would the user perceive it there are
lots of ways to find out how to analyze
that one way is Gestalt principles it's
a really big word four principles of
good figure or how to make something
look of good I've put four of them up
here I think they're close to 15 there
abouts and sometimes they're called laws
otherwise other times they're called
principles really they're just good
rules of thumb because there's always
ways to break them but basically we have
the law of proximity that means if
things are close together they feel like
a group two people are walking down the
street and there's a huge gap between
them or like aa blur two people walking
down the street there's a guy on a girl
walking down the street in the
shoulder-to-shoulder like oh okay maybe
they're together or something
lot of proximity how close things are
together the law of similarity things
that look the same act to the same and
this works for buttons links anytime we
see a web page where like links are blue
usually and when you hover over them
that gives you the little hand icon and
we've learned that so anytime we see
something similar we're like I can click
it click you think I can
click it there's also figure-ground
distinction where the figure like me
right now it's what you want to focus on
and the ground is what's behind this
what's behind me if I wanted to blend in
so that you guys couldn't see me I would
probably wear a suit that looks like
this and then I'd stand back here and
then you'd see a floating head but you
want to see the rest of me and that's
how we can kind of talk about figure to
ground distinction right you can see me
really well cuz I'm wearing a black
shirt against a white background
there's also law of common region where
things that are share the same border
feel like a group so if they're in the
same boundary the same border they feel
like a group that's law of common region
let's go ahead and take a look at these
in the wild first one over here this is
a an email that I got from century I use
century for logging what's going on on
my web servers it sends me messages
about all the people from foreign
countries trying to hack into my
computer do bad stuff about it that's
why there's the failed password invalid
user thing over there and it sends it to
me and you can see that we can see some
of these laws so the law of proximity
these info messages are close together
they kind of seem like they are together
we see the law of common region there's
a line dividing this this area is for
the logo this area is for the type of
alert and down here is for just a few
action buttons and because of that
horrid horizon line that's what we see
we also see the law of similarity the
blue things they look clicky so I think
I can click on them which is awesome and
you can click on those as well also it's
a little bit hard to see on the
projector but the background for this
email is light gray on gray which is
back over here and it's a subdued color
which doesn't draw attention to itself
and because the white is so steady and
stable your tron to be white so that's a
way to group it there's also a border
around the hole
saying this is the content the
background is just the background here's
another one we have a dashboard and we
can see the laws that play over here we
have the law of proximity all the
metrics are close together the
foreground is really bright the
background is dark you're not a you're
not really drawn to the background it's
a bluish slate blue navy blue there
abouts and you're not really drawn to it
because everything on the front is
really bright it jumps out at you the
bright blues you're seeing that the red
when the numbers of the metrics cards
cards are a design pattern and you're
seeing cards over here cards really
encompass the law of common region it's
a region around what you're looking at
that says this data together is all
together that's a way to group it I want
to group these things so that you see
that this is a group this is how it
works
using cards as well as a really great
way to get into responsive design
because cards move around they're really
easy to move around next let's take a
look at a page so this is Typekit kind
of like google fonts and Typekit over
here we can see law of proximity they
give you lots of generous space between
the different elements and then the
elements that are together they put them
really close so they really exaggerate
the extremes over there that's what
they're doing that's what they're trying
to do to go through that and the law of
similarity well we have clicky things
once again the green looks clicky the
buttons you can click on them anything
that's rounded square looks like an
action button I can action it I can
click on that and do something with that
that's really cool and finally we have
an app Instagram the law of commandery
the law of figure-ground distinction is
really prominent here because the
picture jumps out at you and the rest of
Instagram is kind of not really there
that's the point they want you to scroll
they want you to see more pictures so
the pictures vivid everything else you
can pass it over the edge
buttons are wireframe and once again
they probably went with wireframe
because they don't want to draw
attention to it as much and that's one
thing that you can do but their
wireframes but you can tell they're
action buttons because all of the action
buttons are very similar so that's it I
think I should talk about whitespace but
instead I'm gonna talk about Japanese
bento boxes I love Japanese food I was
in Japan for a long time I was there 8
years and you see bento boxes everywhere
this is a bento box I love it
it has my fish stuff where fish stuff
should be it's separated from the sour
sweet tasting stuff and my wasabi stuff
cuz I don't want that on my rice and
they're all separated we got the sushi
stuff up here they're all separate
compartments I know where everything
goes it goes in this place they're
awesome oh we got a super packed bento
box over here we got separators in there
that's the separator sushi stuff fish
stuff they're all separated the juices
from the different types of food aren't
gonna flow into each other so when I eat
my shrimp
it tastes like shrimp it doesn't taste
like pickles I don't like pickles pretty
good stuff there's another bento box
four squares very geometric and you got
your food stuff and your rice stuff and
then over here we got stuff in stuff in
stuff man you can really put regions
around these things and finally high
class bento box
I got containers for your containers for
your containers for your containers
you've seen webpages like this they're
doing it to help separate things put
things in boundaries I guess what I'm
saying is if you take a look at design
Web Design
well done Web Design you might see some
bento boxes this morning I was fortunate
to make a bento box for my wife this is
it I took a picture I'm like I'm tossing
that on my slide this morning that's it
got the rice stuff and the cheesy stuff
and the cold stuff to the side and then
you pack that up and you got your
Avengers again there we go
awesome
so if you go ahead and take a look at
design BAM that's a bento box I should
have changed the colors
that's terrible design you could scold
me red on black outer projector that is
terrible on the computer you can see it
over here you can't but yeah you see
that that's a bento box
we got another bento box over here we
got the red and the things in the things
and we got ourselves another bento box
and yet one more bento box a tall bento
boxes good design good spacing good
white space bento boxes awesome so now
let's go ahead and I'm going to give you
some resources and some ideas for you to
go ahead and start moving forward first
if you have a chance I think you should
go through and look through some grid
systems grid systems are really good
especially if you're going to be working
with the CSS grid directly you need to
understand grid systems and how they
work if you're working with a front-end
framework not so much you can just start
going but eventually you're going to
travel into grid systems so take a look
at that there are lots of different ones
you want to browse through a design
system if you want to go to sleep at
night you're having trouble sleeping
actually look through a design system I
know I'm not read that snot good PR for
design systems but they're like 300 page
documents of how you should make your
application fit the standards of Apple
or Microsoft or Google they have tidbits
and gems in there go through take a look
skin find the gems the rest you can
leave it unless you actually have to
conform to all of the standards for that
platform also take a look at dark theme
trends right now we're seeing a lot of
dark themes all over the place because
people don't want to get their retinas
burnt out looking at white screens all
the time for today's talk I used a
bright screen on my text editor but
usually it's really dark you come into
where I work
it's really dark my coworkers are like
you're so dark like I'm a black man I'm
dark
I got a black shirt on dark and I wear
black so dark silent and then we have
Jennifer dEWALT's 180 paid pages in 180
days project you should check her
project out she spent one day making a
webpage each day getting progressively
more difficult it is awesome and she
made lots of mistakes she left them out
in the wild in the open for you to see
it's a very good attitude to have to say
I'm going to try something and even if I
fail I don't care if other people see it
she got 180 pages and you could see her
skill increasing as she went on she
started with this is text on a page -
this is how you upload an image to my
web page people did bad stuff with the
images so be careful then it went from
that to this is a random text generator
to lots of things and she just kept
going please check out her project it's
on github and you can also see her blog
and her webpage finally some books these
are some of the books I recommend Steve
Krug don't make me think is a great way
to get into usability UX design user
research and just the whole process that
I talked about here if you're looking at
learning how to sketch I'm not gonna say
learning how to draw because as soon as
you say draw you start thinking amazing
art and we don't need to go that far you
just need to have enough to get it done
this shows you how to get it done it
gives you some exercises and practice
that you can do every day to improve
your sketching look at stick figures a
different way she made some awesome
stick figures in it I have these books
here by the way so that after the talk
you can come see me look through them
and if it's something you're interested
you can go online and get the books next
is designed for hackers if you're really
into programming or like I'm a
programmer programmer and I'm not gonna
do design because I don't understand
design it doesn't make sense you can go
through read this book have some good
information for you it goes into depth
on a lot of the things that I've already
talked about but in ways
makes sense to people who came from a
programming perspective and then finally
thinking what type this is a dead spoke
if you're like I want to know everything
about typography this is where to start
if you want to read a book cover to
cover and then find good references
about how to use typography this is a
good book it is really dense though just
a word of warning we also have some
online resources a lot of they talk came
from these resources that you can get at
the interaction design foundation the
design process they go into depth on
that the glossary of human-computer
interaction that's a glossary of things
that you need to know when talking with
other industry professionals about how
to talk about how users interact with
your pages they also have the link to
the gestalt principles that I talked
about next travesty travesty media and
they have a video on Emmet how to use
Emmet as a way to start learning CSS and
how to speed up writing HTML and finally
use Erb foundation grid you can go and
check out that video it shows you how to
use a front-end framework bootstrap you
just do a search for bootstrap you can
find bootstrap up there as well
and you would be good to go that's it
I'm gonna open it up for any questions
if anybody has any yes
okay so the question was a good place to
go to find information about how to
design for usability using your product
and how to make things usable for users
for example people who might have
problems seeing with like colorblind
green red green issues it mm-hmm
hearing impairments where you'd be using
the Aria tags in your HTML a good place
to start would probably be the Nelson
Norman website by Don Norman he wrote a
book called the design of everyday
things it is a really good book he
talked about his struggles with
everything he went to Europe and things
were backwards and kept on running into
doors he tried to open doors that
wouldn't work and his group does
research on usability he also helps with
the interaction design foundation
because that's all what they do so I
would go to nice and Norman first
because Don Norman did a lot of work
there and then you can start going out
from there
good question
anyone have anything else and there are
a bunch of resources I don't have them
here on my computer right now but if
afterwards you give me your information
I can send them your direction as well
because there are checkers that can
check to make sure that the contrast on
your web pages is enough that you can
see them so that you don't run into that
mistake that I had on the projector with
red on black it's good to make mistakes
cuz you can teach people anything else
okay well thank you very much
[Applause]